thank you
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys where we have Jesse Mom
with us today
[Applause]
we tried to introduce her and help you
guys get to know her but instead we
talked about uh Joe doing an enema with
the toilet the vortex yeah we're all
gonna try I waited till the end you did
that was very polite and we were trying
to paint you with
um
unruly colors
my ears are small for the rise of some
really major companies out there but
she's gonna be starting her own tell us
a little bit about it so you know how
dance you guys are getting into the
dance World we're we're in the dance
world oh you are the dance world yeah
just because we roll with this guy we're
in the dancing right right thanks I
appreciate that yeah see that's tutting
oh right Sean Vogue is that what Ken
does
Army
[Laughter]
yeah show me some more Styles yeah
well Bossa Nova we're doing that earlier
with the face and everything no give me
hip-hop yeah hip-hop yeah attitude yeah
take us through the decades yeah this is
hip-hop can you do a little crumping
let's say a little crumping
the moves are wrong but the Vibes are
right
it's impressive
yeah it's all right
give him another one that he wouldn't
know
Rave dancing oh he knows that there we
go
looking at his culture
yeah
that's easy dude
laughs
well I'm trying to be understudies
I asked Anthony every day but he shoots
me down oh you are the shadow yeah
I know Jesus
movement in the shadows we're kind of
like Jabberwockies but not oh my gosh
kind of kind of kind of
[Laughter]
give me pumps we're not into the kinjas
around here I'll tell you that doesn't
end up making it into the
um we're more about Quest Crew dude yeah
this is not this is not getting edited
let's know
yeah what else you got
before we hijack this again oh yeah
like enamored you know we just get
excited
well dance is amazing it's beautiful we
have like incredible talent and
everything but we're actually like you
guys are around the presence of
greatness like Ken Jones right that's
what I say I know there's so many other
dancers out there and
working as a dancer is really hard yeah
it's like similar to acne like it's it's
there's like resources out there but
it's all fragmented and it's all up to
you yeah that's why we employ a lot here
yeah we're gonna
one of us
thank you
so my app is basically the taskrabbit
for dancers so you can hire dance
services oh that's tight it's not gonna
have a dancer bring me coffee I would
love that sure
move I want to learn is you walking to
Starbucks yes hey dancer my toilet's
brother come fix my [__] toilet
you're like hey dancer [__] wait in
line at the DMV for me get your ass back
in mind I see you're out of line I can
see you on your Dot you're not in line
get back in life make sure you pre-block
his email before he blocks is that what
it's for not for no no not like hey
Charity work it's like okay Bart is
teaching a an advanced Crump class yeah
okay in a studio I can book you or as a
private student I'm like I really want
to learn from Ryan I want to learn
breaking Basics and then he teaches for
like whatever 100 an hour and I can book
You full time so you're not like more
like 200. thank you so it's kind of from
like a dance
students point of view and you can kind
of look at like the menu of like who is
doing what and then I get to know their
like hourly rate right away exactly
exactly is it like online classes or is
it like we're gonna meet face to face
it's like both right it's um there I I
say it's booking for Real Time class so
it could be in a studio it could be
private in person or it could be private
virtual but it's not like a pre-recorded
tutorial because that's dangerous
territory but it's more like I'm
employing you for that got it yeah hence
the task rabbit parallel that's cool
what inspired you to make that I
actually after CZ I was like I don't
want to work I was like trying to look
at my resume and like ew like I don't
know
[Laughter]
no it's just like the idea of going back
to like a nine to five was really not
appealing to me so I'm like what do I
have what am I good at what can I offer
to make money and I really like teaching
beginner adults it's very specific like
I don't teach like this cool flashy like
stuff that's like more marketable I like
teaching Basics and to like absolutely
like [__] nerds I'm following all my
students
I don't know how to dance at all and
then you could teach me yeah like people
who are like not confident in like going
to the club or like you know comfortable
in their skin I see so that's like my
target audience I'm like how do I Market
that so I made a website by myself I
like connected calendly and then I'm
like oh I have to take venmo payments
and then I'm like this is all so
annoying and I realized that
um from all my time of working for the
dance student I noticed all these
instances where dance teachers and
dancers the dance professionals were not
supported and so and that's even hard
for all the people trying to employ them
too like you don't know where they are
you don't know how much they cost you
have to slide in their damn fans like
you're never gonna reach them you have
to negotiate it's super awkward so so
yeah just it's a dance Marketplace it is
it is that is actually the tagline our
genius are you going to um provide one
for erotic birthday parties
that's the question I get all the time
because it's like I need yeah yeah like
I want Anthony Lee to pop out of a
birthday hey get the [__] cake dancer
yeah and then and then do a happy
birthday
song oh I mean you could do that for you
just that's a personal negotiation yeah
can we set it up something I have
already employ him so I could probably
get him to do it but I still think um
I would like to go through your app
because I want to support oh thank you
it's cool what if we put them in the
cake but then we we didn't we never
opened the cake we're just like oh we
forgot about the cake
sweet
everybody can spit on it yeah I'll be
right there and you'll have an epiphany
the best thing about it is so a lot of
people are asking you so that means that
the service is in high demand right I
guess so also I think that the it's the
industry that needs it yeah because it's
such a wild west like it doesn't make
any sense to really be a dancer there's
no actual framework of how you can
navigate it's so lucky because what is
it is it just like
it can go from DMS to like Word of Mouth
to it's just so yeah and agencies you
have no control over your work and if
like even the most talented successful
well-connected dancers don't make that
much money yeah and it's inconsistent
it's genius though how do you have power
right yeah like if you're an Uber driver
you can decide I'm gonna drive for like
10 hours a day and make a bunch of money
or I'm not gonna drive today like you
can you have autonomy but dancers still
don't have that time yeah because back
in the day when I was getting started
into the dance world we had to go to a
crack Park and risk our lives and you
see a jam and then you're just like I
hope this guy is cool enough to teach me
a few moves yeah yeah and then I learned
from Legend concert yeah
where a guy is selling fake IDs and at
the corner that goes like this yeah and
then there's a homeless man probably
doing something with his body and then
at the same time there's a gang fight
going on and then there's guys just
dancing and you're there like just
hoping that one of them will teach you
something this is MacArthur Park yeah
yeah that's how we learned from pop and
Chuck
one of the ogs so OG that's something
not everyone knows
yeah he invented [__] strutting dude
I did not I don't know much about
dancing I mean yeah but I didn't know I
didn't know who that was it's cool not a
big shredding guy or maybe he just
called himself an OG and we're like yes
you are
the old guys that do that
he knows uh he was he was from the bop
and Andre era it's those guys yeah
totally so you learned how to dance from
him
yeah but I didn't practice so it sucks
because I got the ogs to teach me but I
didn't retain it because I ended up
doing comedy
yeah I'm glad I didn't join that world
it's it's a tough world it is I was for
a long for a long time I was part of the
um initiative that was trying to
unionize dancers it's called dancer's
Alliance it's been around since the 80s
so it's kind of like a sag before death
yeah but it it's it's so any sense of
movement
[__] [__]
it constantly does not work out very
well because dancers don't have
organization and they always undercut
each other but don't they it's not
wouldn't that be something that they
want but it's hard because let's say you
have a let's say you have a a big uh
thing where you're like okay everybody
We're not gonna do any gigs under 300
bucks that work on set for music videos
and like we agree on that yeah so all
they're going to do is go all right well
then who is down and then all those new
dancers are gonna take it and you can't
blame them because we've all done that
like we've all done free gigs it's hard
you know there's too much there's too
much Supply
have you ever seen a dance audition dude
there's yeah there's a lot there's a
[__] ton there's like 300 people and
then like for uh acting it's like 10.
well that's that's what makes this app
good is that like when you have an
audition right there's a specific skill
set they're looking for and you
disqualify like 100 dancers that day
right but each one of those answers
probably does have something they can
offer individually
but nobody knows what that is so on an
app like this they can go and say like
hey I teach this I do this like if you
just wanted to learn a wedding dance
which is a highly underrated Market it
happens a lot exactly it happens a ton
and what do they do they go on YouTube
tutorials right but they can't get an
actual lesson they can't get someone to
teach them at the level that they need
they're like the dance choreographer
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
I think to your point there are a lot of
dancers the supply and to me especially
now with Tick Tock and YouTube and dance
shows and breakings in the Paris
Olympics next year yeah like it's so
mainstream and dance used to be this
sort of like everyone understands that
it's there it's like the backup dancing
like it's a part of culture but now it's
actually really in the Forefront of
culture trust me the answers will come
out of the [__] walls around here
over there through that hole
[Laughter]
signals this it's a um a lot of values
there and it's being evaporated because
there's no system yeah yeah it's a lack
of system how do you even build the app
do you have like investors or you know
someone that's like programs like how do
you even start something like that so
this app isn't very Tech heavy because
if you think about it it's not like AI
we're not like innovating right like
it's it's a tech platform that has
existed before it's a tech stack that
like Airbnb or Rover or taskrabbit uses
right is it like how e-commerce people
just go straight to Shopify or something
like yes yes basically so we're using
sort of like an out of the box template
as a prototype so it's like an open
source it's open source thing okay yeah
so I have a Dev team and but it's it's
very minimal like they're just
customizing it like they're like oh
let's change this field to like class
type or something right is it like
Craigslist minimal no okay
I'll show you guys big black booty
searching for a little Asian man
description
okay so it looks kind of kind of like
this would be like the dancer's face
cool on mobile oh this is like what they
teach oh and a big thing also is like
um dancers lots of dancers but they
teach a lot of dancers teach right and
that's really hard to sort of like
like offer yeah right because there's
again there's no system so it doesn't
mean that like people with big
followings are good teachers and vice
versa so here you get ratings for your
teaching that's cool oh it's like Yelp
too yeah that's what my mom always said
like those those that can't do dance
congrats that's awesome that's a big
deal I like it it's like it's like a
meet and greet but also like a cameo but
also like a Craigslist but also like a
Uber
all in one all marketplaces but specific
to dance and I think like that's cool
it's the specificity that makes it yeah
yeah because I feel like it's like
cooking I think everybody should know
how to dance it's just being human and
if you don't you suck at being a human
yep I'm gonna use that tagline you suck
at being a human yeah that's nice Joe
could be your first human dance
instructor yeah everybody else robot
everybody else robot I like it because
it does have that um you know like
taskrabbit was a in itself was a great
way to get things done like let's say
you have an electrician he could be
working off tax grab it making lots of
money but he's not winning America's
best electrician yeah but if that's the
only opportunity then that sucks for him
right well as a personal trainer I use
an app similar to that and it makes my
life so much easier because then I just
put my stuff up and then people just hit
me up like oh yeah so what is it called
I use thumbtack that's the that's what I
use or there's so many different apps
you could use but it's what's your
rating on this you do not want it but
people go like I need to get trained and
then they could see you in my area you
know based on what I offer whatever my
profile they can be like okay I would
want to train this pick you use it just
me like this
he doesn't want business yeah
hey do you get a cut from these dancers
you get you get you get um every time
they book a job or whatever is that how
it works I get a cut from the custom ERS
from the customer our mission is to help
dancers make money so we don't take
money from the dancers
that's me when you brainstorm these
ideas yeah do you draw on a napkin how
does this or do you go on word like
what's your like thinking I do draw I
like literally had like a chart of like
dancer and like different Services
different customers and then I drew out
the app yeah that's tight cool did you
do this all by yourself or do you have a
team it happened up here but once I
understood what I was trying to do I hit
up actually a lot of my non-dance
founder friends because it's um it's a
different art like knowing what the
product is is different from knowing how
to build a company so I have a lot of
friends who are in startup world who are
founders who are in VC world and they
help me basically like the reason I'm
making the Prototype now instead of
looking for investor money right now is
because technically I'm a first time
founder and
dance like we can see here too it's
something that like
it's not as easily provable as a market
if you don't know it so it reminds me of
kind of like how gaming was or Esports
was a long time ago when there wasn't
like people are in it like they
understand the fandom they understand
like the culture behind exactly right
exactly and how big it is or even
YouTubers are like that wet one yeah the
big studios never really saw that we
were like a big Force exactly so I think
I need some numbers to prove out that
there is traction and then yeah if
you're launching this beta to see the
following to see how it works all that
stuff I'm launching the beta because I
already know I already have like dancers
who are like ready to use it and so
basically I have dancers and Studios and
students who are basically taking their
existing activity so if you you already
trained me it's like no we need that
activity on the app so let's move it
over so that's gonna happen and then the
cool really help your app like where can
they go to find it if you guys want to
learn how to dance like an abusive basic
human being if you want to do the shoe
one or you hold the shoe like that
yes it's on get work work with the e
um
get work I like not yet I want to work
as the app and you download getwork.com
it's a website oh getwork.com and then
on the website you get the app there's
no app oh no app no no just a prototype
for now very early as a as an
entrepreneur that's also a woman have
you ever uh optimized your menstrual
cycle yes you do yes do you know about
cycle syncing
oh and the ovulation phase like I like
my instinct Stars up so like she likes
to [__] like research and then this
cycle my follicles are [__] going
crazy so like I'm in she's in a blanket
and it's like this is when I like read
the self-help books like she's like
optimizing her ah yeah what's that mean
it means that the world's designed for
men you guys wake up in the morning when
you're like ah and then you're
energizing I love that right yeah good
for you what's it like yeah you guys are
on a 24-hour cycle we're on a 28 day to
31 day cycle so so you do do that I do
so when you're brainstorming and stuff
do you go okay cool like this is my
creative phase this is more like my
administrative phase or I try to it
doesn't always work out that way but I
just I know where I'm at mentally so for
example right now you can feel where
you're at yeah I just ended my period so
I'm in like that congrats you know like
that type of
can I get this every time every month
can you explain who huh you said you're
in the will but I don't think like a
like a open like
fun phase yeah and then right before
your period That's when you get like
yeah yeah yeah when you say this
is that like [__] sad oh sad I get that
and I get like irritable I see let's try
to figure it out and my skin gets weird
we used to be on a 24-hour
um schedule but then once you get
married you just join your wives yeah
but she just lets me know which is a
nice little hat tip she's like hey just
so you know I'm about to go on my period
and I'm like oh okay I have a Google I
have a Google event for like my ludial
luteal phase what is the face for that
that's the 10 days before your Cycles
before you menstruate but was that is
that the instincts phase or
creative phase or it's the sad face for
me so is that the you look over legal
documents during that time or how do you
optimize that she does accounting oh how
does that benefit your mind State
um I get a little more introverted so
it's it's more for like solo reflection
and journaling and like I think that's
actually where a lot of the creativity
and the brainstorming comes in and then
period And then after is like this this
energy is like when I go and do things
like I hibernate and then I'm out of my
cocoon do you have a coffee cup that
says boss [__] on it do I look like I
do
[Laughter]
oh yeah on top of all that look her up
because she's an amazing dancer so look
up Jessie I'm turning into you like all
the compliments yeah no that's because
she's so underrated like as a dance she
never is gonna say it so I'm gonna say
it like look her up right after this
you're around so many good dancers I
feel like I'm like I'm around a couple
yeah
she's so good guys so look her up Jessie
ma uh and then go to oldest video and
then that's the one you watch oh yeah
foreign